this is day three of the government
shutdown and the first day off for
hundreds of thousands of non-essential
federal workers the Senate is struggling
to get those people back on the job a
vote is scheduled today on a new
short-term compromise but there's no
clear sign that it will pass crucial
government services are closed across
the country they include the Library of
Congress Independence Hall in
Philadelphia and the National Archives
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with the
Senate deadlock that still centers on
immigration Nancy good morning good
morning here is the latest the Senate is
scheduled to vote at noon today on a
bill that would reopen the government
and fund it for two and a half weeks we
do not know if that vote will pass
negotiations continue but what we do
know is that pressure on these lawmakers
grows exponentially as this shutdown
moves in to the workweek let's step back
from the brink Senate Leader Mitch
McConnell came to the floor late last
night the shutdown should stop today
with an offer to fund the government
until February 8 and a pledge to turn to
dreamers after that it would be my
intention to proceed to legislation that
would address daca border security and
related issues but his intention did not
satisfy emic rata cleaver Chuck Schumer
we have yet to reach an agreement on a
path forward that would be acceptable
for both sides for that reason I
objected he wants an ironclad assurance
that Congress will provide legal status
to 700,000 young immigrants currently
protected by the soon to expire daca
program Arizona Republican Jeff Flake
shuttled between the two men all day
said the gap is shrinking we have a
commitment to move to immigration
everybody heard the majority leader say
that as they inch forward national parks
and landmarks are shuttered and half the
military's civilian workforce is
furloughed the families of two army
soldiers killed in a chopper crash this
weekend will have to wait to receive
their death benefits a charity has
stepped in to cover the costs shutting
down the government is like chemical
warfare
bang Tennessee's Lamar Alexander is one
of 22 moderates senators Democrats and
Republicans who met in PACs this weekend
trying to craft a compromise made any
progress in there I think we're talking
to one another
one sign leaders are getting closer the
finger-pointing has subsided at least
for now listen it's not a win for us if
first prize in a government shutdown as
you get to be dumb not dumber Senate
Democrats are meeting this morning to
discuss leader McConnell's latest offer
and that bipartisan Senate group is
meeting as well the tricky balance here
Jeff both sides are looking to save face
and end this but they also need to show
that they got something out of this mess
too tricky balance to say the least
Nancy Cordes thank you very much